I lost everyone I've ever loved.
Then, they locked me away...
...with nowhere to hide from the pain.
I need to get out. I'm gonna escape from here.
There are armed guards everywhere and if Blue finds out, we're dead.
We're already dead.
You're afraid, don't be. To reach you're own paradise, just let go.
What you're imagining right now, you control this world.
What are you looking for?
A way out.
I'm going to help you to be free.
You will need to find five items. The first is a map,...
Take cover!
...then fire,...
...then a knife,...
...and a key.
The fifth thing is a mystery.
Begin your journey. It will set you free.
He knows what we're doing.
It's the only way we can get out of here.
If you don't stand for something, you'll fall for anything.